ah yeah think think think think think
think think Oh BA the Jojo your podcast
yeah good high five welcome back guys
well knocked also um since our last show
which was lastly so good solid show I
feel like the more busy we are the
longer it seems since the last show yeah
so it feels like a while since last show
true there's all sorts of things feels
good to sit down yeah no yeah it does
and uh we what were we podcasting about
this weekend
well Jim has an idea for podcast I think
you guys'll like it first the sponsor
this week for the podcast is Squarespace
yeah thank you squares day you know how
much we love Squarespace squarespace.com
is one of the easiest ways to make the
best looking websites for yourself that
you could possibly do they make it so
easy so good-looking you can get a 20%
discount on your first Squarespace
project by entering jayjay at checkout
go to Squarespace calm hit the link in
the description jayjay chugger you get a
big discount yeah yeah and you can try
it for free also guys so thank you
Squarespace for the sponsor thank you
Squarespace and make sure you get
yourself a website because you're not
acceptable not to happen anymore yeah
we'll talk about that later more anyway
anyway so what I wanted to do for the
podcast because still one of my favorite
podcasts that we've ever done is Julian
sucks that celebrity trivia and that one
you know we sort of did I understand and
there are plenty of comments that it's
not that fun to listen to the audio
version of that because you know there's
a lot of quiet pauses and I was showing
you a lot of pictures
so I've quick correction 10% off your
website types a Deb's everyone to check
Squarespace thank you for Jackie yeah um
so we're gonna do just like a lightning
round at the end of pictures and what
I'm gonna have you do is take your
headphones off and like close your ears
the best you can and I'm gonna whisper
to them who all the celebrities are okay
there's about 12 of them got it so is
this so for those of you that aren't
familiar with that first podcast you can
absolutely go
I can watch that or listen to that
because it is one of my favorite things
that exists because like in our daily
conversation when I'm trying to talk to
Julian about you know a celebrity or
something going on Julian nine times out
of ten has no idea who I'm talking about
getting better but you are getting much
better and also some of the things that
I'm into a pretty niche so it is what it
I guess that's true um but it was really
funny the sometimes Julian can't
differentiate again like between
different people which is very funny
yeah so the way that I set this up this
time is the first round is going to be
my questions to you they're not
necessarily good or bad there's my
questions that I wrote then we're going
to have a true or false round okay
then we're gonna have a multiple-choice
round right then we're going to have a
Twitter round the ones that I asked for
on Twitter don't worry they're nice to
you thanks guys
and then the last thing that we're gonna
do is the the picture round which should
be pretty fast there's only twelve and I
will tell you guys beforehand who it is
alright that sounds good I'll cover my
yeah alright let's get going alright
Julian you are you in a good headspace
for this I mean I get headspace to show
you how little I know you just love it
so much you're really cute
thank you okay alright first round is
Jenna round because you're my question
who is the host of Jeopardy
I'll try yes absolutely make sure did
you have it like a second guess yeah Bob
Barker but he's a different host of it
well who's the host of wheel fortune uh
drew Carey no that's another show
why are you doing this it's just started
David I don't watch any of those [ __ ]
all right they've been on forever I
figured that they were safe questions I
know the answer I just like I've watched
it with you well unfortunate do you know
the format of Wheel of Fortune like what
happens um yeah I spin the wheel and
then what we have to guess the word
fortune before the word is that the one
where they spell out the word yeah we
played that on our iPad just fell the
fortune yeah we did with it okay who
stars on we book wheel for its Pat Sajak
yes hey Jeff who stars on wheel of
fortune with him hmm
I'm wheel of fortune fortune is it a guy
or a girl
what to carry I don't know you're
talking about is coho feelings are you
asking sort of it well yeah the voice no
it's a woman uh Dan Hawaii
I thought you I thought she was jeopardy
didn't she didn't think it's a practice
reading these very serious trivia but
she's just she's up there like turning
the answer of I thought that's there is
a girl who does that right it's just
some girl though no that's not that show
no it's loud I was so sure that anyway
it was on Jeopardy
alright moving on please okay um who
used to host the price is right popper
yeah you got that one okay um what did
Marilyn Monroe do for a living
she's an actress yeah good glad thank
you had you got that one to him okay who
is the lead singer of the group maroon 5
a Lavigne yes what TV show is he on the
voice yeah you're crushing it I know who
hosts the show The Voice I like on stage
yeah Nick it no Nick Cannon
no oh [ __ ] there's like so many of those
how was America's Got Talent then okay
Mario Lopez no really it's not Mario
host the voice oh it's the voice seems
like on stage the mic yes hmm
Carson Daly's not that guy right it is
it's Carson Daly oh he's the host I
thought he was one of the so he's the
host what you thought he was one of the
what a guy in the chair you thought he's
one of the
yeah can you name any of the other
judges on the boys pasture president
yeah can be the first letter of that
guy's name what that guy come on the guy
why don't you don't wake up
what's his the first letter of his name
the white guy yeah B the second letter
okay he perseveres last no we're not
doing one just know I know his name you
can't so you can't name any pastor prior
kids either judge Lee Shulman yes yes
that was it was that the B yeah yeah you
is how did Carson Daly get started in
his career he was in a boy band no he
was on TRL yes I was gonna say what is
TRL I don't know what it stands for but
it was like a it was like a MTV show
back in the day right yeah what was it
did you ask him what it stands for what
the show was okay it was the show it was
the one that you ran on the watch right
yeah but what was it
she's like Carson Daly so well what did
they what did they they talked about
like um they son it is for Total Recall
live I believe so they like had just
guests on and sing and stuff
there was like singers on the show and
they did like live I mean sometimes TRL
was it like was it like um like a baby's
not gossip show maybe I'm getting that
confused with a [ __ ] video game
nobody calls them is it always like it's
like the top requested videos la
possibly nothing like that yeah yeah not
Total Recall is that a [ __ ] video
it's a movie I'm on Total Recall as a
movie you just kind of come use it the
movie that came out yeah um I guess I
don't even know what TRL stands for any
more it's like one of those MTV shows
where they have like some of the hottest
music playing and they play like the top
10 most requested music videos Carson
Daly yeah Stan Total Recall live [ __ ]
that makes no sense
um okay yeah that's what he did do you
know what Carson Daly used to be really
good at when you
you Dolf really yeah huh
he was like competitive and stuff yeah
the players just stalk him oh I used to
work in the same building ISM I know I
always used to say that you guys fart in
the same chair we did we fart on the
same gender for about three years okay
can you name five people who have been
cast members on Saturday Saturday Night
Live from any time I always get this
wrong Tina Fey yes Kenan yeah that's his
name right yeah Amy Poehler yeah she
counts Oh what are their names
uh Seth Meyers yeah come on agree one
more this is where I choked Will Ferrell
yeah you didn't Kyle will be playing 20
questions yeah they always ask a
question or were they ever a cast member
I know often times pick a lot of funny
people I'm like all right were they ever
a cast member on Saturday live because
it's an easy way to whittle down lots of
funny people and he's like ah I don't
know man
not know I don't okay who was famously
caught lip-synching on Saturday Night
Live Oh like was a musical artist yeah
Lady gaga no have rovinj no she around
what do you mean was she around was she
ever on Oh probably I don't know was it
a guy no well I mean look several people
since this have been have been caught so
she was the first she was yeah Kelly
Clarkson no no it's not Kelly Clarkson
that's her what Mya's Harris no Billy
Ray Cyrus no oh it's a girl
I don't know Ashlee Simpson I was close
with Kelly Clarkson is like where are
you
they're like sort of the more okay flee
soon do you know why actually Simpson is
famous yeah she dated a guy that's
Jessica Simpson she dated Nick Lachey
back up back up back up who dated Nick
Lachey Jessica Simpson oh who is Ashlee
Simpson I don't know her sister really
yeah okay yeah okay so Ashlee Simpsons
fans for being Jessica Simpson sister in
theory yeah got it
yeah okay okay so who was who is Jessica
Simpson married too used to be okay yeah
who now hosts the sing-off which we love
- is that even still around we haven't
heard of it feeling here
do you know what band Nick Lachey is
from yeah can you like the first name of
it no you said it to me like so many
first name the first letter of the first
name of it no are there more than one
name in the name of the band is it one
name band or is it like a three name in
her - you mean words yeah there's two
words in it he hasn't allowed me for the
phone just guess what group was Nick
Lachey I know it you 18 degrees I don't
know you're so closer than 98 degrees I
was one number on number make much
hotter you're getting warmer but you're
still frozen 18 degrees okay um can you
name any other members of that group 98
absolutely not not even close
okay you want to hit yeah one of them is
related to Nick Lachey
John Lachey disease brother yeah Jake
Lachey no this is assistant nose boy
band Adam Lachey Nick Lachey the third I
don't know I don't know Nick Lachey's
brother's name this is real brother
stake brother that's how your thing fix
with a deep Donovan Lachey no Drake
Lachey no
it's short for and dick Lachey drew
lachey yes I think you can say is short
for Richard which would be dick no and
there's also Jeff and Justin Shea no
just as members of group I really like
Jeff I like Nick I watched that show by
the way when I was when my sister like
would watch MTV or whatever when I was a
kid just hold on the reality show with
it hold on it's a question on here yeah
all right can you name any of 98 degrees
as songs no cannot okay I mean they're
pretty good you should listen to them I
definitely heard them I just can't
recall in my name so okay never mind
can you name any Jessica Simpson songs
no you know very like I'm gonna love you
forever
it goes with like the last answer that
I've heard it before but actually
Simpson songs nothing nope that's fair
that's very enough okay do you know the
reality show that Jessica and Nick were
on together Nick and Jessica Nick what
Nick that's newlyweds it shows just yeah
newlyweds
really yeah oh my god can't leave I go
there can't believe you went from Nick
and Jessica just Nick to the newlyweds
not fair yes it is it's incredibly fair
one have a UFC trivia podcast recognized
nine you're more than welcome to and I'm
sure it's gonna be really funny yeah but
I'm in front of this cuz everyone knows
what I don't know and if I asked you
that everyone be like who the heck's
this new senior you could do like
general sports hmm
and I probably wouldn't get a lot of
things right all right okay
can you name any other MTV couples or
families with reality shows in the past
are they present are just gone like in
the old cold are they still on okay what
like previous shows our current password
- Ian's that's not a TV Z probably
and TV oh there was a show about Nick
and Aaron Carter right didn't they have
their own daily so I'm pretty sure that
they did yeah yeah they like had gotten
like fights all the time that was funny
what else there was a Khloe and Lamar no
that wasn't it II know why you were just
so sure though like Khloe and Lamar it's
kind of an obscure choice
you're not gonna want to know why I know
that mmm Shanna Moakler and Travis
Barker used to have a show Dave Navarro
Carmen Electra The Osbournes
any of those yeah I know our new The
Osbournes I didn't know the Dave Navarro
one yeah that one's wears ink master I
missed that show true so do i although
not how [ __ ] whatever let's suck it
oh my god okay do you know any of the
members of the Backstreet Boys yeah Joey
is that no dancing no Joey and
Backstreet Boys Lance Bass was in sync -
right okay because the next question was
in sync members dancing Justin
Timberlake jelly for Tony
Joey okay you good that's all I know
that's all you know and in sync and all
of NSYNC that's all you it's not like
five and you only know Joey Fatone and
Lance Bass and Justin Timberlake
okay that's three yeah whoo but you know
another one he was a host on America's
Best Dance Crew where Lopez yeah Carson
Daly
Mariana Canada no with nany he was a he
was a judge he used to sit next to Lil
Mama oh the white guy yeah start with
d-trix yes
he sat Diedrichs his name is Jay Jay Jay
see see yeah see I knew that and I saw
Chris the one with the brains mm-hmm
got it and in backstreet boys you don't
know one Backstreet Boy though no I
can't remember not not even like one no
because I remember the members of the
better band but you know how you just
had like a you name someone that had a
reality show on MTV hmm it was what was
that that you need that I mean what did
I need what when I asked you the
question do you know of any other
families or I says the Kardashians and
then Khloe Lamar and then what else did
you say I said something else
uh-huh they got in fights Oh Aaron
Carter Nick Carter Nick Carter was in
The Bachelor glass I really liked the
train of thought you just head I'm sorry
I'm just trying to be as like thinking
out loud as I can no I know that's how
she helps me get to the answer no I
appreciate it that's right Nick was in
actually plays also a Jay Kevin Brian
and Howie how he sounds Meyer he does he
does he does he does what do you mean he
doesn't you're such a dick oh okay
who is Justin Timberlake married to you
make good Jay with your mouth yeah I was
thinking that okay what wait what's your
thought right now Jennifer Aniston no no
she's married to our leftovers guy hmm I
like him he's got a nice way of talking
he did um Justin Timberlake he's married
mm-hmm was he married to Jennifer Garner
no but that's not the worst guess you're
close with the first name you're close
it's Jessica Jessica
um I don't know any Jessica's Jess it's
not Jessica Simpson Jessica she's an
actress
Lopez no what's the first letter or last
name B feel yes I knew that I know yeah
I know you have it Alan Jessica Biel I
know can you name any one else famous
that Justin Timberlake used to date
Jennifer Aniston no you said I was close
to that so I thought it might be like I
just trapped me - Jessica mmm
Rihanna no but he did date a pop star
Taylor Swift no think of someone maybe a
little older Beyonce no who would Justin
Timberlake date Nicki Minaj know just
like house when sometimes you're like
really sure of what you like that Justin
Timberlake dated um-hmm who's someone
like around the same age as Jessica
Simpson Christina Aguilera um Ashlee
Simpson no Britney Spears yes used to
date Britney Spears
I knew that yeah he also used to date an
actress he's already dating an actress
true okay you're right I'll give you
that so Cameron Diaz he used to date
came oh yeah that was a long time ago
yeah do you know of any other
celebrities the Cameron Diaz has dated
no she was to date Jared Leto
and a rod I remember the a-rod thing and
she's married to Benji Madden June who
Benji Madden is no
don't you see me exhausted already it's
overwhelming okay um do Justin and
Jessica have any kids not yet but they
want do the heavy how many just how is
it it's good I mean I don't know
personally but everything seems to happy
like when you answer one of your social
No isn't it but they will I can't Julie
alright okay moving on
um the true or false true okay okay
should we do the Squarespace yes alright
Squarespace is a sponsor for this week's
podcast check them out at
squarespace.com Squarespace makes it
very easy to build your own website
online store blog whatever you need in a
website they make it incredibly easy
they have a bunch of different templates
that you can choose from 24-hour
customer support 24-hour customer
support any time of the day you can get
on chat and they will help you out with
your issue you can support and for those
of us that work in the middle of the
night right I mean that's that's very
very underrated and I give you another
Target or grocery store isn't open 25
well you know what I can appreciate we
were on the phone with like time-worn in
the middle of the night and I was like
oh [ __ ] that's great so it's the same
way you have a problem they are there
for you they have a built-in online
store to whatever website built it's
mobile friendly which you guys know how
important that is and uh you know you
just got to try it out I feel like once
you try squarespace you're not going to
really understand how to do anything
else with any other website chance just
what you need go to Squarespace
commenter products code JJ for Jenna and
Julian at checkout you get 10% off 10%
off Thank You Squarespace for sponsoring
us and go check them out alright now
that to this now back to D true or false
traitor truthful hopefully this will be
a little easier can just open-ended
questions
yeah alright you ready true or false
Seth MacFarlane's parents are both
famous cellists true that's false did
you just make that yeah
I thought since he likes those musical
numbers so much that that would make
no I think he's the parents are
definitely they play music but I don't
think that was their notation certainly
not jealous jealous because who's it
cellist I don't know yeah yeah ma yeah
okay Britney Spears his first album was
called Britney no fault what was it
called oops I did it again there's
pretty close that's I think that's her
second one really yeah
what do you think her first album was
called pink mm-hmm Britney no wait we
already just determined that those
skiers oh do you know what her first
single was like her first song it wasn't
you cited it again um she was dressed up
like a Catholic schoolgirl oh um toxic
no that was I was later I was definitely
later candy no that's Mandy Moore what
was it hit me baby one more yeah that's
a good one
so was the album called hit me no it was
not called to hit me skulls one more
time oh I think baby one more time
no baby comma one more time oh my god
hit me comma baby who's called me hit me
baby oh my god okay true or false
Mary Poppins was directed by Frank
Sinatra false yes boss he's not a
director no I thought damn it you're
messing with me okay
true or false Ellen DeGeneres used to
have a sitcom called Ellen sitcom mm-hmm
true it's you yes did you watch it
nope just had a feeling it was really
good it was really funny really yeah
actually it's funny that now she has
Ellen which is a totally different show
called Adam she's yeah Alan yeah
absolutely
okay Jaden Smith is currently dating
Khloe Kardashian
false okay thank you
do you know Khloe's do you know who
Jayden Smith is yeah he's Wilson's kid
mm-hmm the one who always looks confused
right that's the one the boy I feel like
I don't know how to answer that without
getting into a trap um yes that's his
son
yeah uh do you know if ever he dated any
of the Kardashians which one it was
Kylie for a bit true really on it yeah
there's an age thing right there so
that's right okay the dog in the movie
the artist is owned by Matthew Broderick
except the silent film yeah boss is it
cuz I left because it's not yeah it's
cuz you laugh I laughed cuz it made me
laugh as narrating that fair enough just
imagine like hey guys you did a dog give
me a my dog okay Ryan Reynolds used to
be married to Scarlett Johansson not
married I'm pretty sure they're married
Oh true you get back I'm sorry just like
a fling but no I'm pretty sure they're
together for a long time I like Ryan
Reynolds five years something hmm okay
want to move on to the multiple choice
room yes please Hey all right Julian all
right it's got legs
you ready yeah who starred in the 1997
movie Selena
Bristol do you know who Selena is yeah
she was the Hispanic pop star yeah who
died young yeah we watched the movie
down that in Spanish 101 good good where
I'm impressed
um it was the actress multiple choice oh
sorry are you asking to the actress yes
okay
was it a Jennifer Lopez be Sofia Vergara
see Anne Hathaway or deep Demi Lovato
Hey Anne Hathaway she was busy filming
gravity
it was really Jennifer Lopez oh right
yeah it's really Jennifer Lopez yeah it
was not in had the way I didn't think it
was in for those of you that are missing
in case you didn't listen to the last
Julianne sucks at celebrity trivia
he has oftentimes confused Sandra
Bullock and Hathaway and Julia Roberts
to all be interchangeable people they
are the conspiracy
okay who starred in the 1997 film
anaconda co-starring Ice Cube Jon Voight
and Owen Wilson was it a Jennifer Lopez
be Sofia Vergara see Anne Hathaway or
DJP Lovato the same choice yeah same
choices Sofia Vergara it was Jennifer a
little bit again again dang it trick
question
you never saw that movie no I never saw
it's great it's really great maybe we
should watch it you should watch it well
at this point it's pretty cheesy now cuz
I like watching old cheesy movies oh
yeah well it just gives a special
effects are cheesy but it's still good
okay and Jennifer Lopez II JLo ii jus
Louie Louie who got their start as an
mtv for non mtv in living color fly girl
Jennifer Lopez Sofia Vergara and
Hathaway are Demi Lovato Demi Lovato
Sofia Vergara Jennifer Lopez Jennifer
Lopez oh my god
this is not fair are these all Jennifer
Lopez and that concludes your Jennifer
Lopez education oh my god
who was Whitney Houston married to Bruce
Willis Kevin Costner Bobby Brown or NAS
knows there's not enough Brown
it was my videos I be okay and then once
I wrote that question I got to this
point that isn't meant to be very
respectful
okay these next few questions are meant
to be respectful but which one of these
people has passed away hmm
Val Kilmer Christopher Walken Betty
White or Brittany Murphy plenty Murphy
yeah you got it I knew who that was
I'm speaking to email shucks
didn't trip you up on that one okay I
was having that happened we all were
everyone was said um which one of these
people is still alive Anna Nicole Smith
Farrah Fawcett Lisa Lopez or Ray J ray
Jay really guess you did nice okay let's
move on to the Twitter round from our
friend you guys killed me that asked you
questions some it might skip some of
them that overlapped but giggling Lou
wants to know which member of One
Direction is Irish we watched that
interview and I know his face can I
describe his face okay he is like really
good-looking he has like a really he's
like a square jaw but he also looks
really young he's got like the black
hair like no yeah it's him
where's that theory shirt Niall is the
Irish one the blond one oh I mix them up
well one of the one of the other popular
questions was can you name all of the
members of wonder yeah ready yeah Niall
Horan you don't need last names Harry
Styles yep
was his first letter what about your
mother left la zine yeah
Malik KITT yes it's one more two more
Liam Liam I don't know
I'm having a hard time remember than
last one that's good enough we did it
okay it's done um I'm pretty sure this
is either Sonya or someone else had said
just close your ears for a second like
take your headphones off closures from
one second Sandra all right open them
Gillian who is this person who is that I
want to say Sandra but I think it's
Julia seriously though like try remember
said that Sandra Bullock like know what
did it mean
can you okay [ __ ] Fox kisses Kayleigh
wants to know can you name two ariana
grande songs the way yeah and problem
with Iggy yeah good one yeah what
ethnicity are the Kardashians crazy 68 1
so now coming in yeah
good work um Oakley featuring thorn
wants to know ask him to name a couple
Beyonce songs no I don't want to can you
name a couple a couple the autism's
um Beyonce songs
what about booty that big booty Jennifer
Lopez and Iggy Azalea yeah Beyonce
um drunk in love yeah I counts the one
where she's on the balcony doing weird
[ __ ] I'm sorry what she's on the balcony
doing weird [ __ ] it's like filming on a
GoPro oh do you know the name a song
7-eleven don't count it old count that
mm-hmm
do you know Meek Mill is yeah he's like
in a feud right now right with Drake
yeah um YouTube's mom wants to know Meek
Mill or Drake big not real I just say I
don't know paying any attention I do you
know who Meek Mill dates know who Nicki
Nicki Minaj yeah you told me that yeah
so Drake I picked Rick yes yes um you
don't have to you can pick me if you
want to it's just I'm team Drake okay
okay who starred in Miss Congeniality be
Walker mm was to know Julia Roberts
that's no it's Sandra Bullock you know
feeling so angry I know it's Sandra
Bullock how though how was it Sandra
Bullock if it was Julia Roberts okay I
don't know how can you serve me a
picture of her like in that movie cuz I
like not read the second I'll show you
in a little bit okay Carlos carrion
wants to know Paris Hilton wait sorry
the picture you just showed me that was
actually Julie
that was actually cynical okay that was
the person to mix changing Nadia yes
yeah cuz I thought that was Julie
Roberts so I assumed tearin' saying okay
trying okay moving on
Paris Hilton had a reality show with who
someone she was dating no her mom no her
sister
no her dad nope it was her friend Oh
who's also famous her name is Nicole
Richie yes you know that is yeah Jim you
know she's related to yeah whoo Lionel
yeah and her little sister Sophia Richie
to new that is no I don't know Sophia
Richie is her little sister and my
brother's little childhood friend is
dating me Oh cute they got it Paris
Hilton and Nicole Richie had a show
called The Simple Life and Nicole Richie
is [ __ ] ridiculously hysterical hmm
you'd really like her hmm
I've seen her and stuff she was funny
yeah she's been like movies and stuff
right not really she's not really an
anything where have I seen her face then
I've seen her face I know what she looks
like
I could pick her out of a lineup okay
Sonia Hawkes wants to know what's the
name of the girl who starred in Pretty
Woman that's actually Julia Roberts
actually yay oh yeah you got it
oh yeah okay um who was Kylie Jenner
dating right now
yeah Tyga yes I made sure you know that
okay name three uh that was um Maddie
NYK wanted to know that um Gentoo lover
wants to know name three actors from the
TV show Glee cuz your stepbrother was on
it can I name him yeah max Wilcox
okay step brother was on Glee uh Cory
Monteith r.i.p yeah uh and there was one
more one more cast member total okay
Jimmy mr. Shue mr. Schuester that's not
his name what's his name to where you
have a point for character's name
anyone's name Jessica
we were talking about her the other day
oh god okay I'll give you half a point
for mr. Shue
cares like Nayar Dara and Lea Michele
Lea Michele that's her words I thought
she was Jessica nope not Jessica okay
Tyler Michael wants to know which
celebrity played Hannah Montana Miley
sir yeah mega lar underscore wants to
know who did Jennifer Aniston marry last
week I don't know his name but he's in
the leftovers he's the lead role yeah
we'll give you guys names Justin Justin
Yin I like him um do you know any
celebrity couple ship names like what
are what's Brad and Angelina Angelina
yep what's uh Kim and Kanye's Kim yay
yeah you nailed that one um
Mabel Lexi wants to know who McDreamy
and McSteamy are and what show they're
from no idea they're from Grey's Anatomy
never watch that arriver in my life okay
this is a picture this person Oakley
featuring Thorne again wants to know if
you know who this person is and that's
right this is not an Hathaway case it
again yeah she is
look I see it again I need to see
anything continuous I see it look um
just a little again how they benefit is
not Anne Hathaway what's the first night
of her first name J it's not Jessica
Jamie no Jane me just jennifer Love
Hewitt should tell me there were three
names I know that was I've seen her okay
you should be able to get this one by
Mandy stars who plays the lead role in
the movie Jurassic world and guardians
of the galaxy is prep do you know who
he's married to Paris yeah okay
Sony Hawks also wants to know name one
of Tom Cruise's wives um Kitty Holmes
yes okay it's Nina wants to know named
at least one person Taylor Swift is
dated Taylor Lautner yeah I will accept
that answer
throw back to him okay um Carlos carrion
wants to know who is Farrah Abraham and
why is she famous you ever watch the
show 16 and pregnant or Teen Mom mm-hmm
okay fair enough
Lilly mammoth who plays Regina and Mean
Girls Rachel McAdams yeah can you name
any Disney Princesses Cinderella
yeah done how many of you got though
that's not the question oh okay got it
um okay what what country singing couple
recently got a divorce
big marbles theory wants to know yeah
you already named him earlier in the
podcast Blake Shelton mm-hmm should
always marry his ex-wife not Miranda
Lambert hmm which celebrity couple named
their baby Apple my glare wants to know
no idea hmm well no no they just broke
up dumb um nope it's Gwyneth Paltrow
yeah I think you told me that Cody Q
wants to know is Reese Witherspoon an
actress yes
I'm sure that was a real question or
troll question
Sonya Hawks also wants to know which one
of these is a real in singsong hey hey
hey space cowboy ouch that's my heart or
it's gonna be you space cowboy that's
really funny do you know who this person
is with a lot of face paint on Bryan
caraway no it's Liam from one direction
looks like Bryan caraway uh where was
Justin Bieber born how Halle Abrams
wants to know Halle brims California
Canada that's right he's Canadian how
about that
um who's having a kid in one direction
I'm not sure if that's still even the
thing Liam just showed you what's
beyoncé and jay-z's kids name I think
you got that last time yeah last name
yeah
Northwest that's Kanye and Kim two color
blue yeah okay
can you name her Mickey what does it
Mickey something okay Mickey two four
six zero one wants to know can you name
any real housewife from any of the shows
none none none none at all zero I know
none of them not even like NeNe Leakes
nope none of them nope okay okay um can
you name the Five Spice Girls
Sam underscore Ray wants to know can you
name any of them posh sporty look baby
ginger scary you couldn't go that forgot
about them Oh
Julien who did the Little Mermaid fall
in love with underscore Britney 2,200
the guy who's not do you know what his
name is um
Eric Eric are the Jonas Brothers really
brothers Samantha Carl yet yes yes yes
yes okay um Brian J or Bryn Jane took
how many us one more bring change us s
Julian the main character and clueless
and what year the film came out don't
worry about that you know do you know
who who starred in clueless I've watched
that movie it's Alicia Silverstone
moving on I was gonna say Reese
Witherspoon close enough in a min look
yeah okay so you gotta take your
headphones off right now cuz I'm gonna
tell you whose pictures I pulled out and
we're gonna do the same thing we're
gonna do a picture round really quick
okay you're gonna say him all right yeah
I'm gonna see him right now so yeah good
okay there's 12 people I'm gonna tell
you who they are
okay good
hopefully they heard that we don't know
we don't know okay
pictures all right who is this person
Simon Cowell yes good work who is this
person
Josh Josh um Josh what's his name me
look away and then look I gotta okay
ah it didn't work uh no I know his name
I really like him hmm um he's in um what
the um three the first light of his last
name no
he's in the notebook I know no he won't
happen he was using cereal this is what
happened with Bruce Willis last time he
won't eat his cereal he won't eat a
cereal yeah that fine he won't eat a
cereal yeah I know no I know who it is
what's his name go to the next one and
then let's come back can we come back
how's that burger let's go alright who's
this Chris Rock yeah who's this
let's take a Beckham yes good work
this person Microsoft Bill Gates yeah
you're crushing right now who's this she
honestly looks like a Hispanic Keira
Knightley okay who is she
I don't know do you don't know who this
is fever not Sofia Vergara who is it
Salma Hayek okay Jordan who's this Kurt
Cobain yeah who's this person Emma
it's not an Emma she's in Twilight yeah
it's real and yep
I don't know Kristen Stewart yeah
Kristen Stewart who's this person Joshua
yeah it's Jason ah technicals on yeah
baby figured right cuz this King Tatum
yeah that my brothers uh Russell Crowe
yeah
you crushed this time all right now back
to this one and only one that you can't
get cuz you got like all of them except
for Salma Hayek and Kristen Stewart yeah
who's this person is Josh right no his
name is not Josh his name's not Josh no
what why didn't you think was Josh um um
God did this is what remember last time
I couldn't remember Bruce Willis's name
this is what's happening again he's only
dry know all the ladies young pines he's
in um Crazy Stupid Love yep
mmm I don't know what his name is I do
know his name a hundred I know his name
it's not Josh though it's not job Joshua
uh uh you know the meme where it's like
hey girl yeah hey girl what oh I can't
believe I can't remember his name
you want me to help you yeah help me
though Oh give it away okay you want me
it rhymes with snares the name starts
with an awesome stuff Ryan Gosling yeah
see what happens is I got like this
fixation that his name was Josh and then
I was trying to remember a last name for
Josh I understand thank you well round
of applause Julian yay
had him horn dizzy then you did much
better than you did last time and I'm
winning
you're definitely improving so thank you
for picking questions that don't make me
look like an ass no not at all and
nobody thinks that you're an astronaut
knowing about American celebrities it's
kind of stupid but it is funny sometimes
I think people saw again this time look
when we're sitting around and talking
about someone is just like throw out a
name that so not even like close related
it's funny it makes them laugh yeah so
hopefully that's what you take away from
Julian sucking it hopefully Bertie
trivia it's cute and endearing and also
very funny thank you I appreciate you
honestly I appreciate you taking time to
get all those questions together to
create the bass ket podcast because you
know he do that all yourselves oh cause
um it made me laugh that was fun I'll do
this again if you want and I think I
should figure out a good subject for me
to do this to you
agreed you know not something super nice
something that people would know about
but just not you do also thanks to
Squarespace for being our podcast
sponsor so much grayface squarespace.com
enter product code jjf check out for 10%
off your website and let us know how
that works yeah you can make a website
made of nothing but celebrity trivia and
I would never go on it but yeah thanks
for watching and yeah thanks for doing
that yes funny really
Bonnie we'll see you guys next week for
another podcast vibrant later and thank
you for your questions it was really oh
yeah thanks guys
yeah